[Music]
good morning everybody how you all
coping britain bracing for
record-breaking temperatures today as
the heatwave that's gripped the country
reaches its peak the mercury expected to
rise to more than 40 degrees and it's
been the hottest night on record from
what we can see overnight with a
temperature of 26 degrees recorded at
emily moore in west yorkshire we're just
waiting for official confirmation of
that a bit later this morning but our
infrastructure is feeling the heat with
trains council roads melting and
yesterday even some flights suspended at
luton
why because the tarmac melted
this is the scene across west london
right now a level four heat health
emergency has been declared for a second
day meaning even if fit and healthy
people are in danger from the extreme
heat
an amber warning already covers much of
england all of wales and southern
scotland a red warning for extreme heat
is now in force
that's for an area starting south of
london and reaching as far north as
greater manchester and york
on the roads motorists have been warned
to bring emergency kits as 15 to 20 more
breakdowns are expected during the
heatwave
network rail and transport for london
have urged people only to travel if
absolutely necessary as hundreds of
trains have been cancelled no services
will run between london and northeast
england this afternoon
the department for education is not
instructing schools to close but some
schools will allow children to leave
early or wear pe kit so that they're
more comfortable
and the government is advising people to
work from home where possible aish saeed
reports for us now
as temperatures saw the impacts of the
heat wave became clear
and when it came to travel air and rail
disruption was widespread
luton airport grounded flights after the
runway buckled in smoldering
temperatures
here at lickey hills in worcestershire
wildfire engulfed nearly half a square
kilometer it took four fire crews to
stop the blaze spreading
wales has already reported its highest
ever temperature after it hit 37.1
degrees in flintshire and it's expected
that records will be broken again today
across the uk
a 16 year old boy died after getting
into difficulty in berkshire's bray lake
emergency services are face an increase
in call outs london ambulance service
has already seen a 30 rise in calls
since last week they're braced for even
more
like care homes across the country here
in west london they're taking extra
precautions to keep residents safe
boiling
hopefully tomorrow we'll be
no we won't be paddling down the road
it's too hot for me
i have to be careful
because my skin is very tender they are
put in a place area in the care home
that is cool making sure that the
windows are closed curtains are closed
and we also put them
like a basin of water
and some wipes that to just stop them
like that on the exposed areas of their
body
these weather patterns are set to become
more common as climate change pushes up
average temperatures extreme heat is
likely to be part of our future aisha
zahid sky news
well joining us now is transport
secretary grant chaps it all falls on
him um why are we so underprepared
well we've never seen temperatures like
this like literally ever this probably
the big the hottest day in history um
and a lot of our infrastructure is just
not built for these types of
temperatures so
on the railways for example and i i've
tested this and queried it very hard
but it's not just the 40 degree
temperatures we might hit outside on the
ground
those rails can be heating up to 50 60
and hotter
and that means they're in serious danger
of buckling so you end up having to run
the trains slower over them and that of
course causes disruption as well but
gradually we're having to upgrade all
the infrastructure including the
overhead lines which are gradually being
replaced with
the types which won't sag even in
extreme temperatures but that's a whole
new thing the country needs to get used
to bob ward who's head of policy and
communications at the london school of
economics says um there's no excuse he
said we've been reporting on this heat
wave
and we knew it was coming um and we
should have done more about it yeah i
mean we certainly knew it's coming for
the last few days obviously we've been
seeing in the papers this is
infrastructure warming yeah i was going
to say this infrastructure the things
which take decades to build and replace
three years ago when i became transport
secretary quite literally one of the
first conversations i had with the chief
executive of network rail andrew haynes
was about these overhead lines on the
railways which tend to sag in heat
and he talked me through the new
upgraded specifications which are going
into
onto the railway lines where they can
withstand much higher levels of
temperature and we're going to see this
a lot more regularly we we know that
we've seen many of the hottest days ever
recorded have come in the last 10 to 15
years so we're going to see this more
it's a huge infrastructure to replace
and how long is it going to take
decades actually to replace it all so
we're going to have this sort of problem
with the decades to come we are
and you know ditto with things like uh
tarmac on the roads and obviously there
are thousands if that millions of miles
of
roads in total um so there's a long
process of replacing and upgrading it um
to withstand temperatures either very
hot or sometimes actually much colder
than we'd be used to and these are the
impacts of global warming is there a
cobra meeting today uh no there's a
cabinet this morning uh instead i think
i'm not aware whether there's a specific
cobra meeting
today should be the end of the
experience of the year there is no
hottest day ever yeah but the big cobra
meetings throughout including official
ones do not go well the prime minister
chairs cabinet which is the sort of the
ultimate body is at work cobra sits
under um that a lot of times people
misunderstand how cobra this which
stands for committee uh a cabinet office
briefing room uh is the name of cobra it
is literally that it's a cabinet office
briefing cabinet sits on top of that so
it's more important if you like and i
know the pm has been keeping in touch
with it he was on the phone to me over
the weekend uh about and we spoke about
several aspects he just dials it in then
well
yeah cobra is actually chaired
officially by somebody called the
chancellor of the duchy of lancaster
which is a cabinet colleague uh called
kit malt house yeah we had him on
yesterday and kit's job is to look after
the civil contingencies secretariat
sometimes um chair cobra then yeah it
depends what the issue is so for example
when uh ukraine literally when the
country is melting is that not a big
enough issue well it's not that's not a
big enough issue but cabinet is a bigger
uh if you like a bigger platform uh for
a prime minister than uh cobia which is
a subject last tuesday uh sure yes but
as you said we know it's been coming for
a long time
so he's complacent about it i i look i
just don't i know where you're going
with this i just i'm saying that the
prime minister should be in charge the
cap prime minister is in charge and i
look i just don't agree and it's a
mischaracterization of the way that
these things operate people think
because it has cabinet offers briefing
room ahead of it it somehow is more
important than for example cabinet where
we held a cabinet last week there's a
cabinet this morning uh who's uh in
touch with all his ministers about it
and the as i was mentioning the chance
of that let me just complete this point
there is something called
hold on one second there's something
called the uh civil contingency
sectariat so that's the organization
within the cabinet office that looks
after civil emergencies this kind of
overheating for example there is a
minister in the cabinet well i think
it's absolutely as emergency
there isn't a cabinet minister call the
chancellor of the duchy of lancaster as
an old-fashioned name for it whose job
it literally is to to do this stuff and
look after it and he's been doing that
very admirably as you say you had him on
yesterday morning yeah and you don't
feel that the prime minister should be
leading from the front when it's a civil
emergency so so he has been he's been
being brilliant he's been partying at
flipping checkers
again you know i know you love this
media narrative on it it's just like
that's it bash the media that's what we
should know no no it's just it's just a
sort of it's just he needs to be seen to
be leading from the front and he's not
because he's checked out no it's
literally not true in fact in fact
exactly the opposite is is the truth um
one second uh one second is literally
the opposite is the truth uh in fact
he's been interested in and involved in
the detail of for example uh ensuring
that what's he doing this for because
because in the end he has responsibility
for britain he's leaving in six weeks
so he still has responsibilities why
didn't he do it two years ago
i'm sure he's been up in uh raf aircraft
before
he's leading britain's security at a
time of war and you're telling me the
prime minister he's leaving in six weeks
he does not need to do a maverick
maverick-style photo shoot like that
look that's that's that's your view i
don't i don't think it's only my view i
don't agree with you because in the end
the prime minister is in charge of this
country security there is a war going on
in europe why on earth would he not go
and meet with the because we've got a
civil emergency with the heat rising
higher than it's ever been before it's
quite possible to do two things at once
okay obviously not uh reports that rishi
uh soon act spoke to liz trust after
this uh channel four debate on friday
and said uh why why are we doing this
this isn't working what was he talking
about i'm not privy to the specific
conversation but i do think that um
there's already been two
um debates public debates as well as
many different hustings for the actual
electorate at this point which are the
conservative mps
and i think they took the decision
collectively as candidates to say
actually they wanted to focus on this
stage which is in the house i'm sure
when it goes out to the last two
there'll be opportunity for more debates
no doubt rishi and others will join that
debate well we haven't heard uh their
views on things like housing uh when
they've gone up against each other or
health
um or uh even really what's going to
happen as far as strike action is
concerned so let me put it to you given
that you're representing rishi soon at
this morning what's he going to do um
about sorting out the housing crisis oh
well i'm sure he'll have very
comprehensive plans for housing uh he'll
be outlining them in the later stages of
the competition evening couldn't he
i know that you would love to have had
them on your program of course i think
my viewers should have the opportunity
and i know
some of your viewers may have caught
them both on itv and channel 4
previously
and the debate questions that they
wanted to put to the member would be who
if i may finish who would be the next
prime minister naught point three
percent of the electorate will decide
who the next prime minister is my
viewers surely have um unless the tory
members have a right to put questions to
whoever whoever would want to be the
next prime minister of course and then
still they've been told they can't hold
on second they're still like what is it
seven weeks to go until the prime
minister's um selected there's plenty of
opportunity to do that
that's right from the final what about
the others well this way you get
this stage um it's only mps as you've
mentioned who get to narrow it down
whittle it down to the final two when
it's in the final two anyone who's a
party member everyone's welcome to join
at conservatives.com uh can you couldn't
i couldn't have lost a few members can
can sign up um although actually i
should mention just for you
you can't vote if you join right now but
normally you you can join there's more
members now than when uh for example i
was uh party chairman under david
cameron so membership's gone up not
point three percent of the electorate
not the population of course what about
health how would you tackle the crisis
in the nhs just that was another topic
that we just discovered well let me just
ask you that one because it was another
question that was put by one of our
viewers who can no longer ask the
would-be prime minister how will you
tackle this was a question how will you
tackle the crisis in the nhs a lack of
access to gps especially face-to-face
hospital weights ambulance weights and
how will you fund your plan yeah i mean
and these are all questions that
questions that your viewers will be able
to put i'm sure to the final two because
i'm sure that rishi and whoever the
other candidate is if it is those two uh
will be able to uh will be happy to
submit themselves to debates so it's not
that people won't get the opportunity to
clarify then is rishi sunak saying that
he will do a head-to-head debate with
liz trust or penny mordant on sky what
first four
i was going to say first of all to take
nothing for granted rishi has to get
through to the final i've no doubt at
all uh that there'll be further public
tv debates and at that point at that
point i'm sure he'd be happy to do it so
will he appear on sky news as a head to
head i can't commit rishi's time to sky
news specifically but i am so saying
that there will be an opportunity for my
uh viewers to put questions to your
candidates now unclear whether this
conversation's about whether he
specifically comes on and the candidates
come on sky news or just so that might
be so that mark no because they have
done two tv debates and as i said might
surely are you saying that the sky news
heroes who are watching this morning are
less valued no i'm simply saying i'm
simply saying they've already done i've
realized he hasn't come and the other
candidates haven't come on your program
but it is the case so i'm sure they'll
be delighted to go on tv um will they be
get an opportunity to i'm sure yeah on
sky news i don't know if it will be on
sky you and the other broadcasters and
the candidates
they were running for long term
yeah um so let's go back to that health
question then um given that they might
not be able to ask the question the lady
that uh posed the question works in the
health service and she'd like to um
tackle the crisis in the nhs she wants
to know how you're going to do it lack
of access to gps especially face-to-face
hospital weights ambulance weights and
how will you fund your plan well first
of all we put in record funding in fact
rishi was responsible as chancellor for
doing that due to coronavirus we've had
these huge backlogs and starting to get
on top of them i was looking last night
at the figures for example for
weights for operations at the upper end
and those have been starting to come
down it's really important that
you know we make sure that the gps are
able to uh well people are able to
access their gps which is something of
great concern uh and i think things like
well i think i was going to say i think
things like some of the new technology
which has been used during coronavirus
can really help so before coronavirus a
very small percentage of um of patients
had the nhs app now people have
downloaded that a lot more they're able
to access and book appointments 14
million people waiting for an
appointment probably by the end but by
the end of this session um by the time
of the next election of it is by 2024 is
that not a priority well so
a massive priority uh right now the
waiting lists are not uh 14 million
that's a prediction that's one of the
reasons why um rishi as chancellor has
brought in the health and social care
levy now that was controversial of
course as you know because it involved
raising national insurance in order to
pay for
reducing amongst other things reducing
the waiting list so when you when your
listener asks what's going to happen
action has been taken in order to raise
the money in order to reduce the lists
which have grown because of coronavirus
as we all know so uh i think research
we're out of time so frustrating nice to
see i see as well much appreciated
looking at the papers this morning most
of them are leading on the heap wave the
metro warns get ready for the hottest
day ever the telegraph makes it very
plain record highs travel chaos schools
chaos and it's going to get hotter the
sun says britain is melting the eye
looks at the reasons behind the heat and
how our climate is changing their
headline earth sends a warning
the guardian points out that boris
johnson has not attended crisis meetings
about the weather just being told there
why he doesn't need to
the star shows a police officer helping
one of the queen's guards to take a
drink of water the headline and you
thought you were having a tough day
the times says the race to be prime
minister has been thrown wide open and
also has the pick of the member of the
queen's guard deli mail says penny
morden's leadership bid has hit the
buffers goodness they've been gunning
for her haven't they
returning now to our top story and a
number of young people have sadly lost
their lives while swimming in open water
during the heat wave they include 16
year old alfie mccraw pictured on the
left he drowned in a canal in wakefield
last monday and then just two days ago
13 year old robert hattersley lost his
life in an incident in the river tine
in northumberland
this morning emergency services also
called off the search for a 14 year old
boy who got into difficulty swimming in
the river thames in west london
yesterday they believe he's drowned the
fifth person to die in open water since
saturday
let's get more now on how the heat wave
is affecting different parts of the uk
should we lisa dowd is standing by for
us at leicester market this morning it's
going to be scorching where you are
isn't it
it is we are right in the middle of the
red zone here and usually this market
hall would be teaming with traders
setting up actually there are just a
handful here today i'm told many have
taken what they're calling emergency
holiday it is just too hot for them in
this hall they describe it as a kind of
greenhouse just too hot for them to
handle and
currently the temperature in here
already i don't know if you can see this
it's around
20 degrees so already scorching it was
the hottest day of the year in
leicestershire yesterday like elsewhere
in the east midlands and they recorded
35.3
degrees over in market harbor likely it
was even hotter here in the city it's
just that they do not monitor it and so
hot in fact just around the corner
they've had to close the city's man-made
beach and fun fair the authorities are
so worried about children burning their
feet on the sand and the generators not
being able to cope in the heat that is
how serious they're taking it here okay
thank you
still to come on the program for you
this morning
sun safety joined by a young footballer
who was diagnosed with skin cancer two
years ago when he was just 18.
speak to a farmer about the impact of
the extreme heat and dry weather on
agriculture
speak to an expert about how we can
future-proof our buildings and cities as
our weather becomes more extreme
[Music]
that's bringing you some news just in on
the uk labor market should we standing
by is paul kelso our business
correspondent hi paul what's the latest
uh yeah morning k we've got some more
information from this curious labor
market the economy is struggling with at
the moment and there's some good news in
there and there's some bad news uh that
your viewers will already be feeling in
their pockets unemployment has fallen
again down to 3.8 which on the face of
it is good news for the economy there
are almost 30 million people in payroll
jobs that's in full-time employment that
is a record again would seem like good
news but there are still more than 1.3
million vacancies in the economy so
there's a roles in companies that they
simply cannot fill because they can't
find the workers and 21 of the workforce
these figures tell us it's still
economically inactive that is they're
out of work and they're not looking for
work for various reasons but the figure
that people will be already becoming
aware is what's happening to pay in this
hugely inflationary environment
inflation is running at 9.1 that's cpi
inflation well these figures from the
ons this morning tell us that that means
real terms wages the effect of whatever
pay you may be getting even with a pay
rise once inflation is taken effect real
terms wages have fallen 3.9
against inflation so
even if you are receiving a pay rise and
these figures tell us plenty of people
are around
4.3 is the average pay increase people
have been getting in the last quarter by
the time inflation has taken its bite
it's down 3.9 percent that is the lowest
or the fastest rate of decrease in real
term wages since these records began
back in 2001 and there is a big group of
public sector workers who will be
wondering what is going to happen to
them given that inflationary downward
pressure on pay well today they might
find out it seems that the government
will announce pay settlements across the
public sector for teachers
for nurses uh for fire uh fire
firefighters and the police across the
board and it seems those figures are
gonna fall somewhere between four and
five percent which of course is below
inflation we know teachers are going to
be okay or we're going to get that five
percent because nadeem zaha with a new
chance so pretty much the first thing he
did was tell you in that interview the
morning after he was appointed that he
would grant teachers between five
percent and nine percent for the lowest
paid but if that four to five percent
plays out across those public sector
workers you can expect unions to say
that is a effectively a pay cut and
pressure for strike action will grow
okay thank you
well the temperatures may be extreme
here but the situation in southern
europe is even worse with deadly
wildfires in several countries thousands
of people have been evacuated from
wildfires in southwestern france heat
records have been broken and swirling
hot winds have made firefighting more
difficult
extreme heat has also engulfed portugal
and spain these fires were filmed in
obacco de valderos in northwestern spain
and is still burning out of control
fires forced authorities to suspend the
train service between madrid and galatia
a video filmed from a train in zamora
shows passengers flanked on both sides
by wildfires the train began moving
again after a few moments and nobody was
injured if a little alarmed
siobhan robbins is standing by for us in
southwestern france now hello to you um
siobhan what's the plan there today
hi kay i'm in testa bouche i want to
show you the smoke so have a look at the
sky behind me normal sky i'm just going
to spin round to show you how dark it is
down there it looks like storm clouds
that is actually thick smoke from a fire
down there the cars coming through that
you can see our official cars being let
through we're not allowed any further
down that road at the moment because
overnight uh there has been a real
deterioration
in the wildfires here you can see the
police blocking the road telling people
to go round they've been 31 000 people
across this area now evacuated due to
the wildfires we've moved to this area
on the coast to try and investigate more
the fire going on there there's actually
two in this region yesterday we were at
the other side and there we went with
firefighters as close as we could into
the fire zone it was mile after mile of
dead trees because many of those fires
have broken out in these pine forests
people being moved from their houses um
also the big problem here is the
temperature has dropped today thankfully
it was 41 yesterday now it's around 29
but the wind is still swirling around
really just adding fuel to the fire and
they're really having big problems here
bringing it under control we've come to
this town which normally you'd see
filled with tourists on the streets
going to get their morning
croissants and baguettes nothing today
absolutely nothing it's a dead zone as
they continue here to try and bring
these wildfires under control
okay for now thank you
also making news for you ukrainian
president of vladimir zelensky has said
he is considering suspending 28 more
senior officials it comes just a day
after he suspended the head of the
country's security services and its
chief prosecutor both were accused of
not doing enough to root out russian
collaborators
meanwhile the russian president vladimir
putin is due to land in iran today for a
meeting with the country's supreme
leader
petrol prices have dropped by one pound
fifty per tank according to the aaa the
organization says
filling an average car could become 10
pounds cheaper within two weeks petrol
prices hit a record high at the start of
the month fueled partly by the war in
ukraine
torrential rain has caused flash
flooding in new york some roads had to
be closed and water poured into subway
stations people were advised not to
travel until the waters recede
couples should be allowed to marry on
beaches in gardens and on cruise ships
according to a body that advises the
government on legal reform the law
commission says existing regulations in
england and wales are out of date and
don't work for most couples tying the
knot
and we've all heard of wedding crushes
but i bet you've never seen one quite
like this before here we go
moment a series of giant waves caused by
a tropical storm crashed into a wedding
ceremony in kailu in hawaii some of the
waves were more than 20 feet high and
sent tables and chairs crashing towards
the guests and this is said to have
happened just five minutes before the
ceremony was due to take place
oh my goodness me
i bet the bride was a bit tearful now
protests are planned in sri lanka today
to demand the resignation of the acting
president should we get more on that our
international affairs editor editor
dominick wagon is in the capital colombo
for us this morning uh hi tom good
morning what's the plan
morning kay well we're going to have an
election tomorrow mps will be voting for
the the new president the people power
uprising that we saw last week sweeping
through one government building after
another hundreds of thousands of
protesters on the streets that's
effectively being put on hold after the
resignation of the hated uh former
president got to buy our rajapaksa and
that has kind of created a kind of
hiatus now these mps will be voting for
his replacement tomorrow and we've had
an interesting development in the last
hour or so one of the four candidates
hoping to become president has pulled
out sanjith pramadasa is an opposition
candidate and he seems to have thrown in
his lot with one of the ruling party
candidates dalla dallas al-apparuma um
who is now i guess the favorite and they
seem to have cooked up a plan together
to form an all-party interim government
that we would expect to uh promise
elections possibly within six months now
their main rival they're running against
a marxist who's unlikely to win but the
main rival is ranal wikram singer who
was prime minister and became acting
president and he has seen us too close
to rajapaksa
for the likes likings of the protesters
so if he wins tomorrow we could see a
resumption of all that that massive
uprising we saw last week now dallas
al-aruma is also seen as rather close to
roger pax or the rajapaksa family who
are now seen as disgraced and very much
hated
but i think he will be palatable enough
that offer i think of an all-party
interim government and the possibility
of elections could be enough to defuse
the crisis so i think we're going to see
more protests today probably nothing
like what we saw last week all eyes on
what happens tomorrow i think the
favorite now is is that sort of joint
ticket if you like the former or the
opposition leader who's a former
candidate now and one of the ruling
party candidates and i think if they win
that could be enough to then allow
protesters come off the streets and for
some kind of pause before elections in a
few months time and the hope would be
that could allow sri lanka to get its
economy back together because the
country is still in crisis and still an
economic freefall
okay thank you
now over the years many of the uk's
biggest bands have made themselves
global icons by touring the continent
including these brothers
[Music]
but now many up-and-coming artists
simply can't afford to do the same
because of the huge jump in visa and
transport costs since brexit a group of
mps is urging the government to fix the
europe touring crisis to avoid the wrath
of angry musicians some of whom face
bills of 5 000 pounds every time they
play overseas
well all sorts of ways to keep cool
right now but be very careful if you do
head outside this is one of a number of
bathers enjoying the outdoor pool in in
the clyde in scotland where temperatures
peaked at 28 degrees i was going to get
up and show you the papers but i'll just
stay where i am the telegraph has this
picture from bushy park in south west
london an unsuspecting swimmer taking a
a dip with red deer in longford river
yesterday our animal friends have to
stay cool as well as we do of course
it's a great picture
the sweltering conditions didn't put off
competitors at the worm charming
championships which is not easy to say
for an anxious anchor and it was in
cornwall
yesterday teams had half an hour to lure
worms out of the cool soil without any
digging how many worms did the whole
competition manage to get out
just the one and also in the eye away
from the heatwave the national history
museum's animatronic dinosaurs have
pitched up somewhere you might not
expect peterborough cathedral is the
final leg of their 15-year tour around
the uk before they head home to london
now i'm going to be coming up very
shortly with some talk about some safety
with a young footballer who was
diagnosed with skin cancer two years ago
when he was just 18 what does he do now
to keep himself protected from the sun
top tips for you
did you get any sleep at all last night
and if you're traveling to work today is
it going to take you longer than
expected because the lines are buckling
and goodness knows what else apparently
it's going to be like this for decades i
spoke to the transport secretary grant
shaps and he told me it could take
decades to upgrade britain's
infrastructure to better cope with this
weather
this infrastructure the things which
take decades to build and replace
three years ago when i became transport
secretary quite literally one of the
first conversations i had with the chief
executive of network rail andrew haynes
was about these
overhead lines on the railways which
tend to sag in heat
and he talked me through the new
upgraded specifications which are going
into
onto the railway lines where they can
withstand much higher levels of
temperature and we're going to see this
a lot more regularly we we know that
we've seen many of the hottest days ever
recorded have come
in the last 10 to 15 years so we're
going to see this more it's a huge
infrastructure to replace and how long
is it going to take
decades actually to replace it all so
we're going to have this sort of problem
with the decades to come we are is there
a cobra meeting today uh no there's a
cabinet this morning uh instead i think
um i'm not aware whether there's a
specific cobra meeting uh today should
be the end of the extra day of the year
there is no hottest day ever yeah but
the bing cobra meetings throughout
including official ones do not go well
the prime minister chairs cabinet which
is the sort of the ultimate body is at
work oprah sits under um that a lot of
times people misunderstand how cobra
this which stands for committee uh a
cabinet office briefing room uh is the
name of cobra it is literally that it's
a cabinet office briefing cabinet sits
on top of that so it's more important if
you like and i know the pm has been
keeping in touch with it he was on the
phone to me over the weekend
tamara's here
not sure about that
about the cobra bits yeah yes the prime
minister didn't share the two cobra
meetings on the heatwave one of them
held yesterday one of them held on
saturday both chaired by kit malt's
house who said that he and others like
grant chaps kept the prime minister
informed and he was fully engaged in the
whole issue of course prime ministers
can chair cobra meetings there was
criticism during the covert crisis of
there not being high-level people
chairing those meetings of course when
it really got going both the health
secretary and the prime minister did
chair at those meetings kit mulhouse
said he was coordinating the response to
this and kept the prime minister
informed but he of course was releasing
uh this video of himself that he filmed
of him in a typhoon aircraft yesterday
which grant shap said he was doing
because he is in charge of our country's
security but we're getting a lot of
reaction to that including from the
london mayor sadiq khan he said it was
obviously a joy ride and he should be
concentrating on matters of state i must
say that did happen last week but we
just saw the footage of it yesterday and
he did he did he addressed the debate
issue i'm not sure
well grant shap said that rishi sunak
and others
felt that at this stage when mps are
making the decisions they didn't need
any more debate and they may have
another one when we reach the final two
who will be decided on by the
conservative party members but i think
as you put to him there are so many
issues which
remain unaddressed because of course
these debates that we've already had
can't go on forever including nhs gps
including this issue of infrastructure
and how much we spend on it and how that
feeds into the vicious debate about tax
cuts between some of the leading
candidates so they won't be challenged
on any of those issues in the public
they may be challenged in private
conservative party hustings but another
candidate will be eliminated today
voting is at lunch time will get result
around three o'clock so we'll be down to
three by this evening at the moment it
looks like rishi sunak is certain for a
place in the final two and kemi badanok
is the lowest place but she does seem to
have momentum so i think we'll see in
parliament today a real scramble by the
three women who are fighting it out for
second place okay um tomorrow's take at
nine o'clock thanks very much indeed
worth remembering of course that at 0.3
percent of the electorate um are voting
for the next prime minister of the
electorate which means that 99.7
of you are not
let's bring you the latest on what is
said to be a record-shattering weather
day for the uk uh and kirstie standing
by for us this morning hi kirstie
hello good morning it's already setting
some records in fact we've had an
extremely hot night you might have
noticed that if you've had trouble
sleeping it's something called a
tropical night where temperatures don't
drop down below 20 degrees all night the
current record was 23.9 quite a few
places have stayed warmer than that
overnight so when i got up this morning
temperatures were already had only
dropped down as low as 24 25 even 26
emily moore in yorkshire so it has been
a very warm night and it's only going to
get hotter as that sun gets to work
today very strong sunshine could see
record-breaking temperatures let's take
a look
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
as we know the met office has issued
extreme heat warnings so we're expecting
quite a lot of dry weather today the
sunshine sending those temperatures
soaring there's an amber warning
enforced widely across england and wales
and a red warning in force across parts
of central southern that's where we'd
like to see central and eastern england
like to see the highest temperatures
today around the a1 corridor could be up
to 41 degrees there are a few showers to
watch out for some thundery ones moving
in to the southwest of england through
the day
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
any schools actually won't be opening
today or we'll close early due to the
extreme heat let's get more should we
saber is it a school in east london for
us this morning hi sam with some kids
being allowed to wear school uniform as
well i believe
good morning kay well i'm at school here
uh in east london where it's still open
uh but and they've got their sports day
today but it's not taking place outside
as uh one may expect of sports day it's
going to be happening uh in dolls and
it's no surprise given that the
temperature today the met office is
saying can reach up to 41 degrees in
parts of india now i've got a
thermometer here with me it's
non-scientific i should stress and uh
it's only what seven past seven thirty
and it's 25
degrees uh celsius it's the reason why
uh schools like this one uh the london
enterprise academy will be closing today
at 12 45 instead of the usual time at 4
pm other schools in the country
have closed for the day others like this
one doing a half day some coming in
their
pe kits as a way of managing uh the
extreme heat
uh but yeah this is the case for not
just in london but across the country
okay okay
thank you
now of course the heatwave presents a
number of dangers one of which is a skin
cancer let's get more um from someone
who knows all too well about that and
that's uh footballer cameron graham who
joins me now hi cameron
hello hi morning morning tell me well i
know your story tell our viewers
uh so february last year 2021 when i was
18 and
i was diagnosed with skin cancer
about five months after my best friend
spotted a mole on the back of my
leg and it was about a two three month
process
eventually luckily i got the all clear
so
um yeah it was a bit crazy last year
yeah scary as well i'm i'm guessing um
how are you now
uh well touch with um i'm all good i've
not had anything since all clear um i go
for checkups every three to five months
um in the hospital just my skin and
stuff like that and
every every checkup i've had has been
perfect so long may that continue
uh yeah absolutely um what are the
warning signs what should people be
looking out for what was it that your
friends saw
uh so it was just i was on the beach um
when i used to live in north america in
scotland then it was a it looked like a
freckle and to me it was a freckle but
to him it was a dark uh small mole
and to feel luckily enough he's smarter
than me so
and he knows what to do in that
situation but um honestly it was small
look out for anything small or large it
could be anything
yeah um and you went to the doctor you
must have thought i don't want to waste
the doctor's time but i'm just going to
go anyway just to check
and then when you heard that it was a
skin cancer what what did you do then
she said you had you had treatment quite
quickly but it must have been a
challenging time for you and indeed for
the family as well
uh yeah um i don't think i'll ever
forget that day um going into hospital
and getting told by the doctor that
um stage two melanoma but to be fair
everyone the surgeon the doctors that
helped me i got my operation and my
treatment started within
say three or four weeks i think it was
so
um
it went fairly quick and i kind of kept
myself busy in between and obviously it
was hard for my family as well it was
it was just weird um being 18 and
i have saying you've got
cancer which is horrible um
and i know it was hard for my family but
luck then i feel stuck stuck together
and we got through fairly quickly
that's great news um what's your top tip
for people in these extreme temperatures
just look after yourself and for me
and what i'd advise is this sun cream um
all the time and top up avoid getting
burnt um because you never know what
effect that can have on the moles on
your skin
on your skin in general so just really
look after yourself in terms of
something
okay well i'm glad that you're well
cameron uh you also keep an eye on any
moles and make sure you go straight to
the doctor
yeah one of us
okay thanks a lot
well farmers mean time across the
country also having to deal with the
consequences of the weather on their
crops and their livestock uh rupert she
knows with us uh now um hi uh you i
think i'm right in saying your farm is
coyton barton farm in south devon hi
it's great to see you thanks for joining
us um you've got beef cattle sheep and
and also um some grain how are you
coping
yeah um
yeah we are sort of struggling through
really the water table's very low and
actually getting water to livestock
um you know both the beef and the and
the sheep here on the farm has provide
you know proved to be
uh challenging at times we've got
through it um sometimes by the skin of
our teeth but we've got through it fine
and we're up and running again now
we've had to
uh seek to get water from another source
um but yeah we've managed to get through
it the crop seems to be getting
uh quite stressed in places
which is a worry but i could be the
biggest worry for us on the farm at the
minute is uh the grass growth and you
know our cows and our sheep graze graze
the fields
um you know most of the year and the
grass now it's so dry and hot that the
grass has basically all but stopped
growing uh so we're actually having to
feed
the grass that we would cut and bail and
turn into hay or silage and feed
throughout the winter we're actually
having to instead of cutting it we're
fit that we're grazing those fields now
um
so
we won't have as much fodder in our
stores going into the winter which is a
big worry and lots of neighboring
farmers are doing the same thing and
also feeling silence that they've
already made
and that's as a real worry for everyone
as to you know you normally have this
big bank of fodder going into the winter
to see through and uh we're just we we
don't have that at the minute and that's
yeah it's real worry for everyone at the
minute i think really
and also like arable crops getting
stressed and affecting the quality
yeah i just wondered about the animals i
mean because you know some of them have
got woolly fur coats on at the moment
haven't they how they coping with the
heat
yeah so the sheep have all been shown
off we sheared our sheep off sort of a
month ago and just before well
especially just as the temperature
started rising from the spring to the
summer and it's very important to make
sure they're nice and cool um but with
our so they yeah they seem to be all
right but you know certainly looking for
shade and with the cattle we put our
bulls back in with our cows recently to
get them back in cast the calve next
year but with all this really hot
weather we are concerned that they will
get stressed because of the heat and
that our conception rate
might well be lower now and then that
will affect our productivity next year
okay um just before i let you go is that
a cow on your hat
yeah he said it's a cow print hat yeah
i love it so you've even got a sense of
humor in this weather how are you coping
in in this heat
yeah not too bad you the main thing is
just to keep covered up wear a hat put
some sun cream on drink plenty of water
it's farm safety week at the minute and
you know this is one of those things
that extends to farm safety week really
i think but one of the biggest things
for us as farmers of the minute is the
public it's really really important for
us for the public to back us up you know
we manage the countryside around us if
people want to see the countryside
managed in the future in a way that
everyone believes in and agrees with and
wants to see beautiful countryside all
around then we need the backing of the
of the people when you're eating your
breakfast today your lunch if you're
eating anytime in the future buying food
from the supermarket your restaurant
whatever it is please go in there and
have some british produce whether that's
british wheat to make the bread you're
eating whether that's british pork for
your sausages or british beef for your
steaks or british carrots for the
vegetables it doesn't matter we we need
this support now more than ever the
government policy
is not worth the paper it's written on
in my opinion
through this support we'll also be able
to back up the wildlife that everyone
loves and it's great to see around in
the countryside and also we are
producing the safest most traceable food
in the whole of the world
and it's great to have it here on our
doorstep and available but we really
need the public to go out there and just
buy a little bit more british produce if
you possibly can please thank you very
much
okay it's great to talk to you thanks
for being so passionate about what you
do it comes through thank you
thank you tom
now you've been trying to catch a train
or board a flight over the past day or
so you may have noticed that the uk's
infrastructure is not best prepared for
this level of hate talking about that
weren't we with grant chap he says it's
going to take decades to fix it same
story the world over as climate shift
cities are having to adapt their
buildings transport and even food
supplies to keep up with the climbing
temperatures let's speak now to iggy
bass who's the founder and ceo of
cervest which uses climate intelligence
to identify how cities need to adapt hi
iggy it's good to see you thanks for
joining us so what do we need to do what
are your tips
well um i don't think it's
i don't think it's a simple solution we
do need to think about how we plan
cities how we think about cooling cities
how we think about fun cities i think
this is not just an event kay we have to
think about this as a long-term trend
and as a long-term trend how do we want
to live how do we want to work how do we
want to plan our building so if we are
likely to see more heat waves and the
and the probability is that we will see
many more heat heat waves like this
until we can get to net zero
then that's going to present massive
challenges for business for business
continuity we've seen what's happened at
luton airport yesterday with the great
western rail as well schools closing
down
if this is a trend then we need to start
preparing for this if you want to live
differently if you want to live with
this risk yeah but how do we prepare for
it i mean looking at you know lots of
skyscrapers that are going up here in
central london which is where you are at
the moment
a lot of them are mostly glass and so in
these temperatures you need to have the
air con up high in order to be able to
keep those inside cool and and on and on
it goes
absolutely and this is where we need to
think about the design phase of new
buildings new assets new schools new
hospitals how do we build them in such a
way that we can say well these need to
be a lot more reflective we need to
weatherize these assets in ways that can
withstand these types of temperatures
but also what do we do with the existing
stock of assets buildings hospitals
schools that we have how can we retrofit
these schools um hospitals buildings
in ways that can withstand some of these
pressures that we're likely to see going
forward
so and that's a combination of sort of
governments businesses coming together
do we have the right incentives for us
to retrofit buildings
okay it's good to talk to you thanks so
much for taking the time to explain that
to us very complicated issue come in and
talk to us in more detail when you have
time thanks a lot
keep cool
now to help you get through the hot days
and nights we've collated some of the
top tips to stay cool
uh first up our top tip for getting
through the day it's important to cool
yourself from the inside by drinking
plenty of fluids but avoid alcohol or
caffeine i find that if i have a cup of
tea i get hot but then i get cooler
again
apparently they used to do that during
the during the second world war didn't
they so
i'm sticking with that uh it might seem
counterintuitive but stay inside and
keep your windows closed and curtains
drawn to keep the heat out or blinds if
you've got them and if you're worried
about a heat stroke soak your hands and
feet in cold water or apply an ice pack
to your arms
and make sure you check in on your
friends your neighbors and elderly
relatives and keep your pets in the
shade
do not leave the dog in the car
and now how to get through the night
prepare ahead by sticking your pjs and
pillowcases in the freezer during the
day then take them out just before you
go to bed
dump your duvet and use cotton sheets
instead ideally one per person they will
absorb sweat and are more comfortable in
the heat and if your home has several
floors sleep downstairs
use a fan to help your body regulate its
internal temperature sticking a pan of
ice cubes in front of it can make the
circulating air even cooler
and if you have phone chargers next to
your bed unplug them so they don't heat
up your devices and thus the air around
them
and if you're struggling with the heat
spare a thought for the guards on duty
at buckingham palace this week
here are some of the ones who clocked in
yesterday and the temperature was no
excuse to leave their bearskin hats at
home on guard was seen accepting
something to drink from his fellow
colleagues perhaps unsurprising
considering those hats are up to 18
inches tall made from real bear fare
which is not easy to say and of course
the guards are known to faint when the
heat gets too much and you would as well
wouldn't you absolutely sweltering in
the heat much more ahead on the uk's
record-breaking heat wave with
temperatures over 40 degrees possible um
today we've been looking at the sun
rising over west london this morning
it's looking pretty hazy although it's
clearing up a little bit now but do do
do bear in mind that the temperature
could be above 40 degrees today for the
first time ever you need to try to stay
cool don't go out in the sun mad dogs
and englishmen do that try not to be one
of them we'll see you at the top of the
hour
[Music]